you know Lenin said when it comes time
to hang the capitalists they'll sell us
new rope this is true their Clemens gone
but we are still you know digging the
ground from beneath our feet because of
this object fetishism which is a form of
addiction which comes out of you know
our dysfunctional relationship to our
prehistory
I think so and then there are two ways
to approach doing something about it one
to go cold turkey to try and just cure
it by I suppose psychedelic drugs and
massive applications of of a different
point of view or to try and mediate it
by analyzing this would be the methadone
approach to try and figure out you know
what is it about this fetishism and how
much of it can be satisfied without
killing ourselves and this is where you
get the virtual reality enthusiasts
because they're saying you know object
fetishism is not detrimental to the
earth if the objects are made of light
in other words the problem is the
physicality of the fetish itself if you
can make the vanish out of light well in
a sense we have this though we have
hundreds of millions of people being
warehoused by television where they live
you know toxic low awareness lives semi
preserved by preservatives of low levels
of ionizing radiation and they live
great she does arcologies where
everybody is tuned to a different yes
well on the other hand would you want
these people driving around and crowding
the pulse and waiting in lines in front
of you and restaurants if all these
people ever so I don't know it's a great
age for intelligence because there's so
little of it the nature of the game is
to to deprogram from all of these
systems of images that are being handed
down and then you know that you make
your way like a pilgrim with eyes open
across some new landscape which is not a
very pretty landscape because you know
Western civilization is in the act of a
slow-motion train wreck
that's what's going on at the end of the
millennium
well the main the only alternative my
profound esteem yeah a kind of Hasidic
complaining I just never shut up what's
happening now is there is so much
understanding running around at the
surface of capitalism but it's all
micromanage somebody who has a
technology for making a better chip
somebody has a better faster switch but
nobody can extrapolate what is the
consequence of all of this stuff at once
and it has there are emergent properties
so that no one can actually predict the
direction that the culture is moving in
and the cone of a projection is actually
shortening not lengthening as
uncertainty is crowding into the system
as more and more factors begin to arrive
I mean we don't know where it could come
from it could come from
superconductivity or cold fusion or
charge transfer or you know and at any
moment some technology technique or
piece of information could arrive which
will just confound the entire situation
people like ourselves what we represent
is an intuition aliy driven underground
of people who have found this to have
some positive or fascinating
impact on our own lives but we are not
an indie ology or a field of study I
mean some of us are simply
thrill-seekers some of us are
pharmacologist some of us ethnologists
some botanist psychologists artists
everybody has a different angle but the
thing has not a meal into a coherent
understanding that the self the ego is
the crowning achievement of Western
civilization it also is sinking the
rowboat and what this stuff represents
is an antidote but this is a cultural
war of such fierceness and fury because
you know people are going to be mighty
agitated when they realize how what
cultural transformation really means it
means you can't take it with you it
means you can't take you know that that
the issue of surrender in a dominator
society is very major that's why these
psychedelics are so politically hot
because you know this the ego for all of
its bluster is a very fragile II
established thing and every wind that
blows carries a certain threat to him
I don't really believe in reincarnation
in the ordinary sense but I do believe
that we are interference patterns of
effects created by people who existed in
the past and the future and you can see
it you know I see a lot of people and I
at least I think I do sometimes I think
it's just the same two-fifty being moved
ahead of me but I'm not sure but but
people give off these resonances of past
time and situations give them off
you know cities I mean it's not so true
in America where everything is young but
in Europe if you know where you are then
you usually know several things
scattered that along a titan chain about
where you are you know what was going on
in the 4th century the 9th century 16th
and the 19th and the this this is a way
of seeing I mean this is really there
this is in everything this is just an
extension of
intuition where you actually see a wider
spectrum of time in people in their
faces what's happening is that the
society is beginning to stretch its
upper and lower boundaries you can now
fall farther and climb higher than you
ever could before I mean if you screw up
in this society you could find yourself
living under a bridge quickly if on the
other hand you know the dice rolled a
different way for you you know you could
be sleeping with Madonna tomorrow